je redoute que la recherche soit pas du
tout démocratique c'est je pense que la
recherche des clubs le sport de haut
niveau
oui c'est pas démocratique l'idée que
c'est démocratique si vous voulez alors
dans les phases stationnaire c'est un
des grands grands épistémologique
historien des sciences dit vous avez ya
trois phases dans le domaine de de la
recherche dans un domaine particulier
il ya une première phase qui est une
phase pionnière est dans la phase
pionnière sont des gens qui sont
audacieux qui brise les lignes qui sont
poids zone et toute leur vie d'accord
c'est les pionniers et puis ensuite il
ya une phase de plateau si vous voulez
dans lequel qui est dite normale dans
lequel les choses avancent petit à petit
on rajoute un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu c'est une phase dans lequel
qui devient collective
c'est ce qu'on appellerait la recherche
démocratique dans lequel et les études
multicentriques avec sept pays européens
chacun rajoute un petit bout ça c'est la
face du plateau au pays malheureusement
après il ya la face du déclin c'est à
dire que le chant s'épuiser puis un
autre chantier qui ne sais c'est comme
ça et c'est tout les épistémologie ce
temps observé ça c'est vrai il ya des
phases
et quand vous êtes à une nouvelle phase
en particulier dans les phases de
découverte
le conflit sont terrifiants parce que et
c'est toute l'histoire comme ça si vous
lisez enfin moi je vous recommande de
lire j'ai changé d'avis un livre
merveilleux de la tour qui s'appelle des
rep et des microbes
la fille de pasteur c'est génial mais
c'est un vrai oeuvre scientifique c'est
pas un roman il y tous les journaux de
l'époque tous tous tous deux qui
rapporte ça pour voir comment pasteur a
réussi avec des en ayant des forces qui
était à la fois des forces politiques
des alliés qui étaient les hygiénistes
comment s'est passée l'idée du germe
ça a été un combat terrible vous savez
que la marque qui était vraiment notre
inventeur à nous de l'évolution a été
condamné à ne plus parler par un type
qui était un immense scientifique qui
était cuvier qui était à l'époque tout
puissant en sciences et qu'il a
réellement rendu muet alors que c'était
plus grands scientifiques de l'évolution
du monde c'est c'est la vie c'est un
sport de combat
je m'excuse mon prochain livre s'appelle
la science est un sport de combat
m